[Music]
well hello boys and girls this is Tim
Ferriss welcome to another episode of
the Tim Ferriss show where it is my job
to interview and dissect world-class
performers and all-around funny people
like my guest today and I'm gonna
butcher his name even though I've known
him for a thousand years
ramiz say T that's RA mi T se thi author
of the New York Times bestseller I will
teach you to be rich has become a
financial guru to millions of readers in
their 20s 30s and 40s gotta make sure I
don't disqualify myself soon he started
his website I will teach you to be rich
calm is a Stanford undergrad in 2004 and
he now hosts more than a million readers
per month on his blog newsletter and
social media
we're meet and his team of dozens of
employees build premium digital products
about personal finance entrepreneurship
psychology careers and personal
development for top performers the IWT
community includes 1 million monthly
readers 400,000 plus news letters
subscribers and 35,000 premium customers
he has written about personal finance
for The Wall Street Journal the New York
Times and has been interviewed on dozens
of media outlets including NPR ABC News
CNBC and the Tim Ferriss show welcome
back to the show remain thanks a lot
it's great to be here and you can find
remain if you want to say hello ask a
question or yell at him on Twitter at
repeat RI MIT and Instagram at roommate
so I thought we could start with floor
mats maybe you could tell me about your
dad and the floor mats you want to start
there yeah all right
so you know how you grow up and you
discover that your parents did things a
little differently and you just thought
it was normal I thought it was normal to
take five days to buy a car cuz that's
what my dad would do my mom would stay
home my dad would take us he would take
a couple of the kids in my family
including me and we would go to the
dealer
it was always Honda or Toyota you know
that and we would start looking around
and my dad would play very innocent like
he didn't know anything about cars my
dad knew everything he knew how much the
dealer was paying how much the holdback
was everything so we'd go we
test-drive it he wouldn't be sure dead
uh and then we'd stay there for four or
five hours and he'd say okay I'm gonna
think about it the car dealers spent
like five hours with my dad he goes no
thanks this price isn't good I'm gonna
go there like what so we literally left
then we go back the next day like we're
basically having breakfast at the
dealership and I remember one time we
were buying a car for our family and it
was like the fourth day okay again I
thought that this was normal and we're
down to the last bit were the part where
the dealers drawing the numbers you know
and telling you like well it's actually
a really good deal and my dad you know
he knows the math he's an engineer of
course and and finally we've closed the
deal and my dad goes you're gonna throw
in free floor mats right these are 50
bucks and the guys like cerner we're
losing money on this car how can we
throw these Flora and my dad says I'm
out of here
and we just walked up and left and I was
like a Vietnam vet I'm just
shell-shocked walking out my eyes are
just glazed over and I'm like we just
spent a week buying this car and we
walked out of here over $50 floor mats
so that's where I learned to negotiate
in the most elite negotiation of all now
where where are your parents from
they're from India and are they
first-generation they immigrated to the
US yep they came here in the 70s my dad
came here actually to study he went back
to India and it was known that he was
coming back he was a bachelor and you
know they sort of arranged things so
that he meets people when he comes back
and it passed around the community that
this bachelors coming back and he ended
up meeting my mom they met by both
families coming together in a living
room and talking and they met each other
the families decided it was a good thing
seven days later they were married my
mom got on a plane and flew to the US
for the first time and they've been
married for about 40 years now amazing
we have so much to talk about and so
much to catch up on it so many questions
that I want to ask but I thought we
could we could start and certainly will
we'll bounce all over the place but you
said before we started recording because
you have a new edition of your book I
will teach you to be rich
noticeably lacking a photograph of you
barefoot on the cover and you have some
incredible quotes testimonials I should
say including from Burton Malkiel author
of random walk down Wall Street but you
said to me because I haven't read the
introduction that you either should have
started it or you did start it with I
was right could you explain please
explain okay
so this book I will teach be rich
originally came out in March 2009 and
let's just dispense with the idea the
name sounds like a scam we both know we
write books that sound like scams but
they're not I mean it's like a running
and I've just learned to embrace it guys
it's the weird sounding book but it's
actually good advice and in the first
edition I talked about long-term
investing low cost investing thinking
about really automating your money and
using psychology against yourself for
positive results now if you had followed
that advice it turns out that when the
book came out in March 2009 that was the
absolute bottom of the recession crazy
enough now I don't believe in market
timing but if you had used the advice in
the book this $10 book you would be set
for life so I started book off by saying
well I was right let me tell you all the
things that would have happened if you'd
use this book I did get a couple of
things wrong I had to change one of them
man the biggest mistake of my life was
putting in interest rates in the book
like okay do you remember what sounds
like me putting doing market testing
with magazines okay so I put in back
then savings rates were 5% remember
these banks were paying 5% so I was like
guys 5% dah dah dah here's the math and
then like the minute the book came out
they dropped to 4 3 2 and then point 5
percent now the point of it is you don't
make money on your savings account
anyway we're talking about 21
dollars a year or a month versus four
dollars like it's irrelevant it's tiny
details every day for the last decade
I've gotten like 10 ml's a day that are
like [ __ ] you where's the 5% you talked
about you liar and so I'm like never
again I'm never putting interest rates
in his book again so I took him out I
clarified it I corrected a couple of
things that I wanted to update and I
added like 80 new pages of material so
things have changed a bit but good
advice really shouldn't change that much
now I have I've had a chance to observe
you as sort of an animal in the wild for
10 plus years and part of the reason I
enjoy having our conversations but also
sharing your tactics and scripts and so
on is that I've seen you use them and
walk the walk which is more than I can
say for a lot of financial pundits or
commentators out there in the world and
I want to to perhaps just mention a and
not really an upsell maybe a side sell
which is if somebody wants to be either
greatly informed on the arts of
negotiating or if you're just looking
for outrage porn to get really angry if
if that's your current sport of choice
you can find a guest post that you put
on my blog quite a few years ago called
how to negotiate like an Indian which
which I can only imagine the response to
that title if I were to publish it no
idea but it's staying and staying the
way it is folks
so there you have it if you want to
google that on Tim that blog you can
find it but let's talk about some of the
perhaps counterintuitive
things that you do because we talk about
all sorts of aspects of finance and
investing in life in general on the
phone just the two of us but I'm looking
at a number of different bullets that I
was hoping to explore and one is you've
mentioned that you've lived in the same
apartment for 10 years why do you still
rent yeah I get this question a lot
because
in America real estate is religion and
if you're successful then you're
supposed to buy right and the old tax
deduction and they're not making any
more land and all these things that we
say that we don't really understand I
rent intentionally I could go buy a
place in Manhattan tomorrow with cash
but I don't want to it doesn't make
sense for me financially and also I
enjoy the flexibility just to give you
an example I love that the building that
I live in has awesome services I love
that anything that goes wrong I make a
phone call somebody there was a it
started raining last winter and water
started coming through my windowsill so
I made a phone call and they came up and
they took a look and they were like we
actually have to replace this part of
the roof because it connects and we have
to send someone to the outside of the
building I said it sounds good to me it
doesn't matter to me I'm gonna be out of
town for the next few days so have a
blast I would estimate that that repair
probably costs in Manhattan on a weekend
probably twenty-five thousand maybe
thirty five thousand dollars I didn't
pay it right so that's a financial also
a flexibility issue which is I don't
know where I'm gonna be five years from
now and if you're gonna buy and you run
the numbers it makes sense to plan on
being there at least seven to ten years
minimum so that you can sort of eat the
cost of the transaction fees but I think
the biggest thing that really surprises
people is that in America we have been
told so many times real estate is the
best investment and in my opinion that's
just not true a lot of the time now I
don't think it's a bad investment always
but I always say you should run the
numbers and when I run the numbers in
Manhattan it just makes no sense I would
rather take that money and I would put
it in the stock market and I know
consistently what that outcome is going
to be over the long term I don't have to
do any repairs and I as we may talk
about I really hate anything that
affects my convenience so I think for a
lot of people I just want people to
think like hey is it really true that
real estate is the best investment for
me it's not it's a cost and I'm happy to
pay the cautious like I'm happy to pay
the cost of you know a basket of
strawberries that I'm going to eat I
don't think I'm throwing money away on
strawberries and
think I'm throwing money away on rent so
you said real estate is is religion or
it can be and I think this is worth
digging into it for a second because
there are a lot of statements that in
certain circumstances can be
conditionally true right like real
estate is the best investment asterisk
fine print if yes ABCDE okay and there
are then there are things that are just
patently I think untrue right like you
need money to make money
false it's who you know not what you
know yep false dichotomy not mutually
exclusive
investing is only for the rich right
ironically the way you get rich is by
investing and there are a lot of
different ways to invest right so it's
so that one perhaps undertone or portion
of context that I think is is worth
talking about cuz I've been thinking a
lot about this myself in the last ten
years is that there are there are
investments that you make to optimize
for financial ROI and then there are
investments that you make which are
decisions about allocating resources for
optimizing other things right so I'll
give just a perfectly seemingly opposite
example which is I have bought real
estate I've also had my ass handed to me
a year and a half before your book came
out in fact hello just about rate
mortgage first home buyer yeah that was
that was ugly but I have I have bought
real estate typically I have used
mortgages of various types and I had a
friend of mine a different Indian who
was also who first-generation who is
this guy we all know each other Naveen
2-car oh okay yeah so thank you Naveen
for this advice by the way who I've
known for ages also an engineer
brilliant guy and we were looking
through different financial decisions
because and I want to talk about kind of
what got you here won't get you where
you want to go type changes right
because I imagine you do things very
differently from your parents totally
even though their behavior makes perfect
sense yes and their conditioning and
their experience what he said to me
looking at my balance sheet there's a
small amount of
principal left to pay on a mortgage and
he said just for your peace of mind for
this primary residence it doesn't make
financial sense
you should pay this off so that you feel
as though no matter what you have that
and it's almost like a homestead right
you have something that on many levels
cannot be taken away that's how you feel
and I did that not saying this is the
advice that everybody should take by the
way
but for me in that moment there was
there was so much uncertainty in my life
to make a decision that seemingly did
not let the numbers line up was in fact
the right thing to do
I completely agree I'm so glad we're
talking about the nuance because I
believe there's a few underlying beliefs
when it comes to money and I believe
that number one most people are mostly
the same and that's profoundly different
than a lot of people who believe that
we're all individual we have different
situations no I believe that most of us
are mostly the same and if we can
optimize if we can basically just follow
good advice for ninety ninety five
percent of the way then we earn the
right to take advantage of our
individual specialties and differences
so for most people that means saving a
certain percentage investing a certain
percentage etc but I do think once you
do the basics then you earn the right to
say hey what are the nuances here where
do the rules not necessarily apply to me
so for you yeah you have the principle
maybe financially it didn't make sense
but it just felt good or it it provided
safety in an uncertain world at that
moment I've got examples in my own life
where I pay for stuff that makes no
rational sense I heard a personal
trainer for the last many years that
doesn't make any sense
I could theoretically find the same
workouts on YouTube and you know they're
all printed out or I could just stop
going with my trainer why he's giving me
all the workouts but there's something
more that I get out of it and when I was
starting out when I was like 22 I wish I
could go back and shake myself because I
was very utilitarian and really
judgmental about how other people spent
their money and I would scoff I would
say you know flying business classes
stupid we're all getting to the same
place I'm just paying 20% of what that
person's paying and what I really should
have done is say why do they do that
like if we're listening to you right now
saying you paid off a principal where
you really didn't have to you could have
just dripped it out you're not paying
much an interest why and for you that
safety was meaningful for me I like the
flexibility and convenience so I'm not
saying don't ever buy a real estate and
you're not saying buy or pay it off
tomorrow but what are the circumstances
in which people who are otherwise
probably pretty thoughtful make certain
decisions and the mistake that I've in
retrospect made a lot when I was younger
and I think that's also it in part
because I grew up with by necessity very
very frugal parents is sounds like much
like yourself I would scoff at and look
down upon a lot of behaviors that had I
actually looked closer and said what am
I missing right all right a bunch of
wealthy people are doing acts yeah they
must know something now I'm like holy
[ __ ] I can't believe I missed it for
like 20 or 30 years like it actually
makes a whole lot of sense okay so let's
talk about what are some examples yeah
what are some things that you scoffed at
in your early let's say teens or 20s
that now you're like oh I get it
well I and you know I don't want this to
sound obnoxious to folks because we're
gonna start to weave we've gone through
many kind of checkpoints right like
we've we've you and I have been very
fortunate and we've made some good
decisions had a healthy dose of luck but
I'll give you an example because you
just mentioned business class all right
like my assistant I have today my
primary full-time assistant still
remembers when Tim this is not that long
ago would get a middle seat economy to
last ticket right because I remember
when I first had people reach out to me
about paid speaking engagements which
seemed completely absurd at the time
number one I said yes to everything so I
was like what people are gonna pay me to
speak yeah sure yes to everything
Molly above and one of the options
that I realized was available at one
point was they could buy the tickets for
me which was if negotiated by speaking
Asian or something usually business or
first-class or they could give me the
cash expected for first-class ticket and
then I could just pocket it and buy a
middle class economy seat which I did
once to Australia yeah for a speaking
gig that was I mean at the time kind of
my high-water mark right like it was a
very important gig it was critical that
I do well the speak engagement and I sat
like you know I might hinged at 90
degrees at the hip in a middle seat with
like my arms
thrust in front of me like a cadaver
like a Dracula for whatever right like
18 hours and got there and I was just
pounded hamburger meat for like three
days and I said okay that was that was
very petty wise and extremely pound
foolish so that would be one example and
I think that's the broader category of
protecting the physical asset yeah what
I like about these examples like I don't
find them shallow to discuss I think
that each of us no matter what level of
your success has gone from a certain
place in life when you're in your early
20s to a different place right I used to
read PC Mag and think about what parts
to build my own computer now I just go
buy a Mac like it's as simple as that
and you know I haven't kept up and it's
just not a good use of my time I just
want someone else to make the decision
for me and it doesn't matter whether
you're buying first-class tickets
internationally or you're going to a
restaurant instead of cooking food for
yourself one night you know one night a
week or a month we all intuitively know
that as you change in life you're gonna
your spending is going to change so I
actually don't think anyone should
listen to your example of a middle
middle seat and say like oh my god like
must be nice to be Tim or for me you
know I have an assistant as well must be
nice it is nice but you might have money
and you don't choose to spend it like
that you choose to spend it on something
else I have a student of mine in this
book who used the book he told me he
retired at 35 and his wife
tired there 35 and 36 and they driver on
in an RV that's their rich life that is
not my rich life but to him that's his
rich life so when I was back in my 20s
what I wish I would have done was to
look at people who had succeeded in the
ways that I could conceive myself
succeeding like I would have never seen
myself in an RV so maybe I didn't have
something to learn from that person but
if I was really introspective and if I
were really curious I would have said to
him like how'd you do it yeah what'd you
do and why did you choose of all the
things to live to travel in an RV if I
done that I would have put myself aside
and all these things that we love to
define ourselves are which by the way is
interesting people love to define
themselves by what they're not you as
opposed to what they want so you see it
on dating profiles everywhere don't
message me if or people say I would
never do that if I had a million dollars
well you don't have to worry about
having a million dollars because when
you define yourself by what you're not
you won't get there when you choose what
you would want to do now it becomes okay
cool like I want this I want that how
can I work to get it so I wish I would
have reframed the way that I thought
about money and psychology earlier on
how do the frameworks or rules
guidelines anything that you use for
financial decisions differ from those
you absorbed from your parents or other
people when you were younger and in
there are a number of different ways to
approach that right like we could look
at sort of the approaches you used to
you mention a million bucks to get to
your first million versus what you used
after that point right because if it's
anything like my experience very
different totally but I'll let you
tackle that any way you like because I
think what's if people could take one
thing from this conversation it would be
test your assumptions and be try to be
aware and it takes a lot of effort and
practice of what rules you're following
or biases you have that you arrived at
through logic and reasoning versus
having simply absorbed over the course
of like bouncing around like a pinball
in a pinball machine in this thing we
call life for the last 20 30 40 years
because those are not your
rulz there's somebody else's yeah I call
them invisible scripts these are the
scripts that run our lives and they're
so deeply embedded in us that they are
invisible to us and you see it you know
one invisible script that I grew up with
was education is always good and I
believe that I believe that's a positive
invisible script I think it's a really
good one
I'm all for an education self
development that's what I do for my
business and in my life I also grew up
with things like you shouldn't pay for
that we could do it ourselves yeah me
too right yeah and so and it really
trickles down in lots of peculiar ways
so there's some ways that I really loved
when we used to take vacations our
vacation was mostly driving from where
we lived in Northern California to LA we
would visit family my mom would pack
lunches and we would stop on the way and
eat and you know what I love about that
is like we didn't need any fancy food
like we were a family we spent time
together that was vacation for us I
didn't know what it was like to stay at
a fancy hotel in fact I never ordered
room service until I was like 20 years
old on an interviewing trip for
Microsoft so I like that I like knowing
that I grew up a little hungry not
physically but just knowing like oh cool
like we're happy we're good there's
another level you know we can't quite do
it right now but we're happy but I think
I also grew up with some beliefs that
I've shed or changed some of them would
be like being really conservative with
my job like if I had followed all the
paths in life I'd be sitting here
wearing like a very oversized Cisco
engineer t-shirt and just you know I'd
be telling you about my sales
engineering stuff like it's a
conservative go get a good job etc and
as I got older and I started making
different choices
my parents were supportive but they were
a little surprised I think on the
financial side I didn't really
understand why people would pay more why
pay more when you can pay less but
there's a famous quote from Dan Kennedy
he says why pay less when you can pay
more total flip of the equation so
whether that applies who's Dan Kennedy
Dan Kennedy is a famous marketing
consultant and he has a great book out
about marketing to the a flow
which if you read it it can be a bit
abrasive but it's also like a very
eye-opening shocking book because what
he points out see most people go through
life with the lens I call it a money
lens they put a pair of glasses on and
they look at the world through frugality
lens how can I save money and you see
this in lots of ways
if you say oh that's a really nice
jacket where'd you get it they'll tell
you and they'll say I I got it on sale
or I got it for 50% off that's
interesting but if you talk to somebody
who bought like a absolute like a
something they love this they went to
Italy and got this perfect jacket that
was handcrafted they would never say I
got it for 50% off they have a different
lens
maybe craftsmanship I grew up with the
frugality lens everything was about cost
growing up now it's also about value so
as Dan Kennedy says why pay less when
you can pay more if you're gonna have an
amazing anniversary dinner perhaps you
that's the place you don't need to save
fifty percent perhaps you actually want
to spend more to create a memory you
will never forget Dan Kennedy
interesting guy I've never met him but
one of his books I'm blanking on the
name we'll put it in the show notes at
Tim that blog four slash podcast but
it's something like million dollar ideas
or how to make the most or find your own
million dollar ideas and it was as I
recall it a collection of different
business ideas and examples which was
really useful for also removing the
financial lens that I would have had on
at the time which was you make money
doing a B or C which were that happened
to be whatever three things I had seen
maybe around me and to show just how
flexible the approaches can be and I'd
love to hear a bit since you have such a
great sample set of students and what
what are some of the psychological blind
spots or rules that most prevent people
from
reaching their financial goals and and I
want to touch on so think about that I
want to touch on one thing you said
which was frugality and and having grown
up with a definite frugality lens I
think this is this is worth commenting
on that is frugality has its place like
you don't want to just be flying blind
because you know what is it a fool and
his money are soon separated I mean it's
you no matter how much money you have
you can spend it all and I've seen this
a lot it's not hard so you have to have
a means of assessing what is worth
spending money on and what is not
however if you make let's just say 20 30
40 $50,000 a year fill in the number but
let's just say $50,000 a year if you
want to reach all of your financial
goals by by cutting costs the maximum
amount that you can cut is 50 thousand
at which point you are you've got like a
t-shirt and you're you're a wandering
ascetic you know begging for food and
and so on
so there is by definition a limit to the
Delta you can create between the money
you spend and the money you have whereas
if you if you have an equal focus on
income generation or even disproportion
to focus on income generation sky's the
limit in in a sense right so that would
be one where like I was trained like cut
cut cut cut cut but if you're not
simultaneously looking at income
generation or increasing income it can
be really problematic 100 percent that's
why most of America and most of the
world has the frugality lens on right
there's a limit to how much you can cut
but no limit to how much you can earn
and if you think about the typical
financial advice it's a very pointed
question to ask why don't any of these
so-called financial experts in the
newspapers talk about how to earn more
money and the answer is they don't know
how that's not their job they're writers
so to be able to understand that you do
need to manage your costs for example
there are a lot of things I do in my
life that are highly frugal highly
especially for the income that I have
and I just it's not of interest to me
but I
like what like my wife makes fun of me
because I run my entire business on a
MacBook Air and you know I put my feet
up on the table I got my thing on my lap
and she's like watch you get a new
computer like that fan is so loud and I
had to how long have you had it so I
that's what I wanted to find out I went
to the Apple thing in the top left
corner and it shows you when you bought
it it's seven years old but like it
still works so I don't want another one
and also when I grew up this comes from
my childhood
we didn't buy a new computer unless the
other one did not turn on so I've kept
that with me and I like having little
places in my life where I intentionally
impose scarcity I think it's healthy I
think it's healthy to have restraint I
think it's healthy to build that
discipline if you just go out and buy
everything you can I think you're on a
quick path to a bad place you're also
aware that you're doing it yeah right
yes exactly so exactly another example
is I hardly ever eat out at all and and
that's a big change from tenure while I
was single and I was seamless like my
seamless receipts are just like through
the roof seamless is an online delivery
service in New York everybody there uses
it and now for health reasons and also
just for cost reasons as well we like to
cut back on that yeah but I spend more
on things so I always like to spend
extravagantly on the things I love but
cut costs mercilessly on the things I
don't mercilessly so I like that I
actually would I think a lot of people
kind of try to cut back a little bit
here and a little bit there and they
just end up generally unhappy about it I
would actually encourage people to pick
the area I call it a money dial pick the
area of your life that you truly love
spending money on like let's do a quick
exercise what's the area of life that
you love it gives you joy to spend money
on travel travel and food Perth say
whether I cook at home or I I go out I
would say and now I you had a veracruz
breakfast taco this morning yeah which
was amazing not expensive no I looked
but delicious at the same time I could
go to say San Francisco to like say Sanh
there and in
way that as an experience so those would
be two areas travel and n food perfect
so let's let's do this now a lot of
people say travel it's one of the most
common ones
mine is convenience I like my life to be
super convenient so I've spent a lot of
money and time engineering that now
let's take your money dial travel and
like a stereo dial let's turn it up
let's say just for easy math that you
spend a hundred dollars a month on
travel again easy math what if you 10x
that or let's say you hundred X that
what would travel look like for you
different than what you do now let's see
well I
it would probably mean that I have which
quite honestly have to thought about
because I've had some given some of the
gnarly crazy places I go I've had some
catastrophes in New York attached trees
I would probably have a fixer on the
ground each place I went I would have
somebody who is on call and available to
effectively fix any problem or tackle
any challenge or want that came up I
love that anything else that's the one
that comes to mind okay because it's
yeah that's that's that's the one that
comes that's the one that comes to mind
all right now what's something in your
life that you spend money on but you
don't really care it doesn't make that
much of a meaningful difference you
clothing perfect okay so this is you'll
find this in college my fans have given
me unending great for you know my wife
is a personal stylist okay oh man all
right she won't like what you talk about
this okay so I love this exercise there
are about ten money dials that I've
identified Travel is a big one
convenience is very rare there's health
and fitness there's relationships
there's a few more what I like to see
people doing is actually spending more
nothing they love health and fitness is
the one where I would Ratchet it up okay
that's where that's where I would turn
the dial though what would you do I
would actually get a trainer which I do
not have currently I have different
trainers for different things but it's
all Alec Hart nothing has been prepaid
or pre-scheduled which is an issue right
I suspect that
part of the reason tell me if I'm wrong
that you like having a trainer is the
accountability and the regularity
hundred percent and I would like to do
that okay I love this by the way
whenever you ask someone about their
money dial you can just see their face
light up right because they love it I
loved I love I'm obsessed talking about
how I have built my life around
convenience I'll take you through every
last detail you can see the joy in my
eyes so what I love to do is for people
to dream big if it's travel it's not
just like adding an extra ten percent
it's like 10 Xing it what would that
look like and then in order to get there
whether it's 2 X 5 X 10 X what would you
be willing to cut back on and suddenly
people start to realize that money
actually should be bifurcated it should
be highly bifurcated it's spending very
little on the things you don't like and
going extravagant on the things you do
and when you start to think this way now
your rich life becomes way more specific
and meaningful to you
you know as opposed to me I don't need a
fixer because I don't travel at those
kind of places and I don't do the kind
of traveling you do but for me I want
even more convenience and now you know I
want a different type of travel now that
I'm married so these are things that I
want everyone to think about what's your
money dial and what if you could 10 exit
it and this is valuable also just for
people who may be listening and going
like waste of time I don't have the
money to spend 10x on it whatever
whatever the pushback might be is a
thought exercise this is very very
valuable in the same way that if like
when I wrote my last book I asked myself
if I only had a month actually for the
last two books you know I only had a
month to write this book how would I do
it oh really what would it look like and
and 90% of the ideas were terrible but
then there were ten that made the
process I was planning on already 2 3 4
5 times more efficient and so the
question itself might seem absurd but
many of the ideas end up being extremely
practical and let's talk about
convenience so what are what are some of
the again what are some of the things
that you do or have found
disproportionately
morning gratifying from a convenient
standpoint well okay I'll tell you but
it's gonna sound weird because like to
me this is truly joyful and to other
people I'm gonna sound like a lunatic
but this is my rich life so I'm gonna
break it down I wake up in the morning
and by the time I wake up early
we started waking up at 6:00 after we
went on our honeymoon we were waking up
early for safari and then we both kind
of looked at each other and we're like
you want to keep doing this and so we do
we sleep around 9:30 10:00 wake up at
6:00 and by the time I get to start
working I just opened up my calendar and
I double-click on whatever's in the
morning it's usually writing in the
morning and everything is like perfectly
organized the link is there I click the
link the document is ready to go with
exactly the right information it's all
organized like there's nothing left to
chance there's no documents over here
there's no files over there it's all in
its place you've prepared this in
advance my assistant has and my team has
so that has all been engineered and I do
believe that the best morning routine is
decided the day before the week before
even the year before so by the time I
get there it's just ready to go it's
like a chef walking in me some plus
exactly and everything's in its place so
I love that then on a day-to-day basis
things like scheduling my assistant Jill
handles that she's fantastic and even
when I was coming here I walked outside
to get it uber taxi and I didn't even
know what airport I was going to I just
knew that when I double-clicked my
calendar it would tell me so it's all
taken care of finally a couple other
examples when I travel especially for an
extended period of time we have
something called the travel protocol and
Jill activates the travel protocol that
means my plants get watered if they need
to be that means that she handles email
in a different way that means that all
these details that I normally attend to
when I'm in the office are now attended
to by somebody else let's get super
boring not for me not for you but maybe
for some people is this a checklist that
lives in a Google document where where
does that protocol once you went once
you click on go go gadget travel
where are the instructions live because
let's say Jill is sick yeah and somebody
needs to fill in we don't have to get
into that complexity if necessary but
the the instructions yeah they're in a
Google Doc there's a Google Doc that's
roughly 25 or so pages of preferences
like when I travel if I'm traveling over
five hours I want to sit in this type of
seat it's all lives there and it's
updated so it's a live living document
one recent thing that I updated was when
I travel for a longer period of time I
want to have food delivered to my hotel
so I can try to stay generally on diet
so I'll get to the hotel and they'll
have a whole foods bag they're delivered
with food that I know that I can kind of
eat on the go and it's got a spoon too
because the first time we did it there
was no spoon and there are no spoons in
a hotel room which I had to learn myself
so it's like a lot of iteration but to
me I don't find it annoying I actually
love it because I'm like cracking the
code of what it takes for me to be
really efficient so it lives in a Google
Doc if my assistant were sick for some
reason she would transition it to
someone else and so it's accessible to
anyone at the company and we just go
from you I want to mention something I'm
extremely particular about preferences
for travel so hotel room not near an ice
machine not near the elevators a very
particular thoughts on if if it's a hip
cool hotel with a really loud Lobby
certain max Heights but take into
account fire escapes and so I mean I
have a whole set of preferences I love
this but when you let's just say that
somebody listening is the thought
exercise had dialed up their travel
money dial what you realize is that in
some cases the things you would expect
to be expensive or problems you would
expect to be expensive to fix are not
expensive like the Whole Foods example
its Sochi so you could do whole foods
may do its own delivery if not perhaps
instacart if not in a place like Austin
you could use favor there are really
inexpensive ways to do this to give an
example so I used to I still do ice
baths and I didn't have what I have now
which is this somewhat
risky MacGyver the cold plunge and I've
engineered which you have to make sure
you've unplugged before you get in but
before that when I was living in San
Francisco I had ice delivered where I
would have ice picked up I would usually
stop at a gas station after the gym and
like pack my trunk full of ice which was
a huge pain in the ass and then I
realized wait a second at the time
instacart will deliver like 60 pounds of
ice for five bucks and I was like I am
that [ __ ] I'm the guy who's like can
i order kettle bells on Amazon Prime for
free so I don't have to pay for like
twice the cost yeah and lo and behold I
was able to do it so the the solutions
even if you brainstorm them in a wealth
exercise do not always end up being
expensive 100% that's why I'm so glad
you said a few minutes ago don't scoff
at the mental exercise like oh I don't
have enough money like dream big dream
the dream of what your money dial is at
10x but the solutions are often so
simple every time I travel I will post a
video on Instagram of the food that was
delivered and it's like classic stuff
it's like yogurt it's stuff that we all
eat it's yogurt it's some almonds maybe
a peanut butter thing and people like
what service did you use that's the
question what service and I'm like the
service doesn't matter you could find
somebody on Craigslist this is like a
$20 purchase $20 that can change your
life and in order to get there you just
have to start with the dream it's the
money is like really the last of it so
this is $20 this is so my I have a very
good assistant it and it's it's taken
it's taken quite a bit of time and it's
not something you necessarily get right
off the bat and you don't need an
assistant for this but she said to me at
one point she's like Tim I don't know
when this was not that long ago
she's like Tim just travel with a roll
of 20s and you can solve almost any
problem and I was like that's a good
idea and I'll give another example of a
lifestyle upgrade that does not cost a
lot of money if you go out to
restaurants choose a restaurant you
think you're really gonna like go to
that restaurant
not on the weekend so say between Monday
and Thursday go either early preferably
like right when they start for dinner
service sit by yourself and again this
is this is this is kind of a one-time
investment go there for a week this is
also stuff I picked up when I was
writing the 4-hour chef because I would
go in with a little notebook and I would
order a bunch of stuff and I would take
little notes and they're like who the
[ __ ] is this guy right number one but
they the chef
typically at that point is not gonna be
as as loaded not on booze although that
happens too but on like 52 menus open it
once that's not gonna happen at 5:00 or
5:30 so they might take an interest on
the maitre d might take an interest in
in you order all sorts of stuff to to
try and then tip like 40% mm-hmm and do
that three days in a row and you are
forever VIP at that rest oh wow so I
like that little insight the 40 percents
not that surprising but the three days
in a row do it a couple of days in a row
so people get to know you you get to
know them Wow and like your VIP for life
okay and sit at the pass if you can so
if there's a chef's table or a counter
where you can see the kitchen sit there
because most people will never ask for
that I love this okay I love how to take
a mundane experience like a restaurant
and turn it into something special so
thank you for sharing that let me share
a couple of my own I had two experiences
one where we I think we got something
magical and the second where we didn't
do it but we got an idea we were on our
honeymoon and we were just having the
most amazing time we went to four
different countries and we started in
Italy then Kenya India and then Thailand
and the hospitality was just like on
another level right we're on a different
planet and I said to my wife if there's
anything you think of or you want just
ask because at these hotels they really
really really want to say yes and we
were at one hotel in Thailand and my
wife loved the spring rolls and so the
the manager comes out and he said
hello you know how's your meal data and
she said you know I was wondering she
was kind of nervous I was wondering if
we could have the recipe for these
spring rolls cuz these are the best I've
ever tasted he goes you know what give
me just a minute he goes to the back he
comes out with the chef's chef in his
hat and the chef says I heard that
you're interested in the recipe and he
goes I would actually love to arrange a
cooking class for you
amazing what time are you available
tomorrow she's like she's like I can
come anytime so she goes to this cooking
class private in the back in the kitchen
not only did they make four different
dishes they even said okay you know your
stove doesn't have as much flame as our
so you want to adjust the recipe etc so
she sends me these photos I'm just
sitting in the room I was doing some
writing and she sends me these photos of
four full dishes and then they were like
here you go compliments of the of the
kitchen like she'll never forget that
never and it was just about asking how
do you do this she didn't even ask for
the class so I learned from that and I
thought that was magical the second
experience is a new thing that I've
added to my playbook which is my buddy
Nick took me he's like hey do you want
to go to a tea tasting in New York I was
like yeah let's go green tea I thought
it would be a typical tea taste thing
you know you go some tea they do we go
there okay there's like six people from
Japan there's a translator and there's a
photographer
we're like what is going on right now
we're like just something happening but
we don't understand what's going on so
we're sitting there and then this this
person comes and starts speaking and the
translators translating and they
basically say this is the best tea in
Japan and it's being brought to the US
for the first time and we're like okay
like how good can good be it's tea you
know like we didn't understand quality
at this level okay so the way that we
truly understood it they told us you
know they only grow it on a certain part
of the mountain and they use these types
of things and we were like okay okay the
way that we truly understood it was when
they put the tea leaves in and they said
okay steep it for a second and they said
drink one drop one drop
we're like what and so we drink one drop
it was amazing it was really I've never
tasted anything like it and then there
was a little thing that said the prices
we looked at each other my friend Nick
and I and we said ounce four ounces is
the most expensive thing we've ever had
to drink if we were to buy it it was
like $70 per sip this is crazy right and
we didn't pay that much for the tasting
but what we learned from that was number
one sometimes quality you can you can
only tell it by certain attributes - I
wasn't at the level of being able to
appreciate it and three and this was the
real key what we should have done and
what I'm going to do from now on is
whenever I go to a cool whether it's a
tea tasting or any kind of interesting
restaurant I'm I have a little playbook
now I asked my assistant Jill to put it
together we're gonna make the
reservation of course I'm gonna pay I'm
not asking for anything free but she's
gonna send a note ahead of time that
says you know hey roommates coming in he
would love to be able to take a kitchen
tour just say if you have 15 minutes
ahead of time he would love to be able
to take it and if possible he'd love to
post it on Instagram whatever again not
asking for anything free but like what
I've learned is people who are the best
loved to share it so I there's this
phrase you know those who can't do teach
that's totally incorrect never believe
that the very best loves you can't wear
those who can do those who can't teach
or they say those who can't do , shot it
yeah and like that's a total misnomer
let the very best people like here you
are you're the best in the world at what
you do and you love to teach everyone
who's the best whether it's a chef or a
tea master they love it so I'm gonna try
to do that when I go to these places and
I'm just like everyone of us can do that
so anyway that was my exciting
experience so you said you said that one
oh that's the one that gave you the idea
yeah I didn't execute that yet and the
the well there are many things that that
one could you take from what you just
said one I want to underscore is the
importance of asking and I think that
you know what I would hope for myself
because I'm still
developing my thinking and priorities
will change and worldviews will change
as it relates to money right money is an
interesting thing we could talk about
like what the [ __ ] money is to begin
with that's a separate thing it's part
of the reason why I have a 100 trillion
dollar note from Zimbabwe framed that I
put up on a wall because it's important
to remember just how conceptual a lot of
this is but my thinking will change but
to stress test your own assumptions it's
very valuable to not just do thought
exercises but certain real-life
exercises so one could be asking for a
kitchen tour and don't by the way don't
do it unless you're interested so and if
you're not interested go watch chef's
table like Francis moment or one of
those I get excited about it and have
some basic vocabulary so you can
appreciate what the hell is being shown
to you if you're gonna do it don't do it
just to do it but that is a question
right and we know someone who lives here
in Austin also Noah Kagan who has his
coffee challenge right so walk into a
coffee shop ask for 10% off and that you
can't tell them you're doing an
experiment you can't tell them that so
once i've told you to do it it doesn't
matter what they say so it could be a
starbucks it could be an indie doesn't
matter and if like what if i thought
what if i don't like coffee it's like i
don't care get a water get a you know
order Pellegrino and we'll order tea but
as for 10% off cultivating the muscle
used for asking for things is so
incredible and i you're talking about
you know those who those who can't teach
and how there are these these common
sayings that are that are taken is true
i do there is one that i like which I do
think is generally true and that is in
life you don't get what you deserve you
get what you negotiate I agree and
sometimes negotiating is just asking for
what you want right so are there any
exercises that you would suggest or
practices phone calls questions to
people who are listening that might help
them kind of stress
some of the things they have accepted
yes I love this so I'm gonna give you a
small one and I'm gonna give you a big
one
the small one is if you have any sort of
late fee you should just use the scripts
in my book or you can google for them
and you should call up your financial
institution usually it's a credit card
and negotiate the late fee what should
they Google specifically if you don't if
you don't we'll get the book but if you
don't get the book but you can just
google remits 18 negotiation scripts
okay and you're gonna see there this is
how it's gonna go you call it the credit
card and you say hi I just wanted to
confirm that I've been a member for the
last four years and they're gonna say
yes I see that
mm whatever year okay great I noticed
that there's a late fee here of $37 from
last month
I'd like to get that waive to please and
they're gonna say by the way notice my
tonality I'd like to get that waived
please why Sir well I made a mistake but
I sent the payment in the next day and
I'd like to confirm that it can be
removed and it won't affect my credit
80% of the time right there you're gonna
get it removed and there's a reason I
put that in Chapter one of my book as
well as with bank fees overdraft etc
it's that most people have never
proactively taken control their money
they just accept the world the way it is
ah the credit card screwed me again no
you can get that back and once you get
that late feedback you're like oh my god
I can actually have control over this
these companies work for me
so that's that's the first thing I would
say the second exercise is a little
bigger it's more conceptual right now
I'm doing a small coaching program with
like a hundred and fifty people I'm
walking him through my book and it's
like this private group and I'm just
walking him through every chapter and I
asked him a thought exercise a couple of
days ago I said if I gave you ten
thousand dollars tomorrow or if you just
found it no obligation no strings what
would you do with it okay Tim what do
you think they said they would do it
this $10,000 $10,000 this is just like
right off the cuff pay down mortgage or
invest in and in index fund but I'm
guessing closer to the former than the
latter I don't know
okay you pretty pretty close so it turns
out that according to these answers that
they're all Saints we have a bunch of
Mother Teresa's in the group they're
like I would pay off my dad I would give
10% to charity I would do this in that
I'm like you got $25,000 a credit card
debt you're telling me that you would
magically take this money and just pay
it off they what they were doing was
they were having a very optimistic sense
of their future selves I would rather
they say I actually don't know what I
would do with this money
based on my past behavior I'd probably
just spend a lot of it or I have no
system or way of thinking about what to
do with my money that would have been
more honest yeah
instead when faced with what we're gonna
do in the future we're really optimistic
I'd work out four times a week I pay
this off I'd pay for my parents
retirement what I would really like to
see people is go through this exercise
start with your optimistic self and then
try your realistic self if you say
you're gonna pay off all your debt why
are you even in debt in the first place
clearly you didn't have a system that
would keep you out of it so I think for
people whether it's $100 $1000 $10,000
whether it's you know you could even go
as big as somebody just gives you a
house what are you gonna do with it I
haven't even done that myself but you
could play with the concept and then
remember if you don't have a system like
for me the answer is I would put it
straight into my system put it into a
checking account and money would be
withdrawn to certain places 20% would go
here 10% would go there some money would
be spit out for guilt-free spending and
I'd probably go buy a beautiful sweater
where do they that's always in your
sweater I know I love where where do
those funds go if you're comfortable
talking about some of the places sure so
you get 10 grand you put into the
checking account and then it gets kind
of put into this process yeah it's like
a projects a process map basically like
an email inbox and it gets filtered and
shunted where it needs to go so day to
day my spending is very consistent
except for two areas rent is the same
food is basically the same everything is
pretty stable I like to put my target is
I start by saying I want to say
invest at least twenty to thirty percent
and I think that's a good healthy number
if you're doing that the rest of your
life is generally in control twenty to
thirty percent and because we don't have
kids right now my wife and I've been
talking about our numbers we want that
number to be towards the higher end
twenty to thirty percent just technical
question is this pre-tax or is this
taking into account taxes it's a great
question it can be either if you I
always like to be more conservative
always so post tax is really good if you
can do that because you're you know
you're gonna be putting more in but
really for any of these numbers if it's
post or pre you're generally in a good
place anyway so then that money is
getting saved and invested and investing
is like I try to go more aggressive on
investing because we're young so I put
that into things like a target date fund
and you know I love Vanguard and I I
recommend them I don't have any deals
with them but I think they're the best
that's where I put what is the target
date fund target I understand all the
separate words but I don't actually
actually know what that is okay so very
quickly everybody thinks investing is
about picking stocks and like sitting
and looking at this screen that looks
like Minority Report
that's not investing investing is very
simple low cost funds and these cost you
almost nothing these days we're talking
a point one percent expense ratio it's
very very low cost what you do is
something like a target date fund is you
pick a target date that you're gonna
retire so if you're thirty and you're
gonna rip your gonna presumably retire
at 65 that's 35 years from now so
there's a target date fund called
Vanguard 2060 fund okay and what that
does is it's like a pie chart it's
pretty aggressive in your 30s because
you're young and as you get older it
gets a little more conservative
basically what it means for you is that
you don't need to do anything except put
money into it automatically every month
I love this as a great simple low-cost
way to invest and the bulk of my
portfolio is either in target-date funds
or individual index funds so that money
would go in there I have some money in
sub savings accounts I've got some
targets like you know I saved up for my
wedding before
was before I even met my wife saved up
for an engagement ring
I like to plan ahead so I have those
numbers same for a down payment on a
house which eventually I will buy even
though it doesn't make sense for me
right now but I still plan for it also
vacation
so like midterm goals you're talking
about roughly one to five or so years
how do you keep these things separate or
is it are they only separate in a
spreadsheet where you're keeping track
you know how do you not co-mingle yeah I
like keeping them separate because I
think it's like separate meaning
separate bank accounts well you can have
sub savings at Kelly's subsidy yeah so
capital want like an authorized employee
on a credit card account or something
like exactly just for tracking for
tracking purposes and I also think it's
nice if you have one big old commingled
account you don't really know what's for
what but what I would encourage everyone
to do is think about what do you want to
save for between one to five years and
for one year there are things like
Christmas gifts like you know that's a
known irregular expense or it's a known
regular expense it's coming every
December so if it's 500 bucks you might
as well start saving now then there are
things like an anniversary dinner
there's also mistakes I used to have a
stupid mistakes account because I used
to get a lot of parking tickets I don't
do that anymore thank God so I don't
need to plan for that but then there's
things like a down payment maybe getting
married things like that above and
beyond five or so seven years I just put
it in the market because I don't need it
and it just grows then you're putting it
in the market with a target date fund
target date fund yeah and those over the
long term over history have returned
about 8% so if you do the math and you
go to one of these calculators like a
bank rate or something you can plug in
the numbers and you'll see that your
money doubles roughly every it's the
rule of 72 72 divided by 10 it'll double
about every seven years
that's why compounding is so powerful if
you start now and you put even a hundred
bucks a month in that number gets very
large very fast so that's the power of
investing the rest of the money pays my
fixed expenses like rent things like
that and finally out pops out guilt-free
spending this is my favorite part the
sweater account the sweater account
that's basically so
that brings me to my two things that are
variable travel I tend to overspend on
travel a bit and clothing and I've set
up this system because now I've sort of
advanced my financial system where a lot
of it is automated I have a meeting once
a month I have a personal CFO we kind of
look at it and I basically told them I
want my document prepared in this way I
want an executive summary
I want the expenses categorized as such
and I only want you to flag the
following ones because these are the
ones I'm variable on like I don't really
care if I spend 20 bucks more on
deodorant that doesn't move the needle
but like too much on travel I got to
know about it so I can kind of correct
overtime that's how I think about the
spending okay so two next topics I
thought we would discuss prenups so this
is a topic that is shied away from a lot
it seems to be an important topic at
least in the US and it's something that
came up in conversation recently and you
joked that you might be willing to talk
about it on the podcast this is one of
those subject areas that is I think
neglected and I've seen a lot of
difficulty and angst and pain and
discomfort faced as a result of I think
an unwillingness to do to make it more
of an open conversation so where should
we start with prenups I'm an open book
man I'll tell you anything all right so
this is one of those things that when I
walked into it I didn't know anything
and I only know I only knew what I had
heard on TV that prenups are bad or
they're for people who have generational
wealth that's been inherited like I
didn't know anything and then I
discovered when I talked to friends
there was so many people who have
thought about this or gone through it
but none of it is online it's all behind
closed doors so prenup prenuptial
agreement what is what is a prenup
what's the purpose of a prenup prenup
sets the terms of what you are coming
into a marriage with and it is a
acknowledgment that
certain people might have certain assets
or interests like a business or cash or
investments whatever the case may be and
it also sets the terms for if the
marriage ends for whatever reason what
is to be done with those assets
specifically the pre marital assets
that's what a prenup is about okay so
how did how did you think about this
because I've I've heard some disastrous
stories of this process being handled
poorly or terms not being perhaps
reviewed as carefully and I should point
out also that I this is not a
male-female thing I've seen this in
same-sex couples I've seen this in cases
where the woman is coming in with
significantly greater assets than the
husband-to-be so how did you think about
this and what's one of the smarter ways
to go about thinking about this well
I'll tell you what I did and I'll tell
you some mistakes I made too and I'm the
reason I want to talk about this is that
I want to shine the light on money
topics that people don't talk about and
I want people to be informed you can
make your own decision but I walked in
to thinking about getting married with a
lot of preconceived notions about what a
prenup was who it was for and just just
to give you a sense like nobody around
me ever signed a prenup growing up it
just was not a part of my culture so I
started thinking about getting engaged a
few years ago and my girlfriend at the
time you know we were discussing it and
discussing what oh the engagement yeah
that you know also bowling what's gonna
happen eventually and you know we're
together for the long term things like
that
and I started looking into it and if you
google how to sign a prenup you're gonna
find a lot of really generic and
borderline bad advice
it's from disgruntled redditors and it's
from like ask men or these just
magazines where they have these things
this advice like you should blame it on
your lawyer or you should blame it on
your parents or how do you get away with
not making your fiancee
and I just thought this is not the way I
want to start this relationship and this
financial relationship as well because
that's what marriage is it's legal its
financial it's also love it's it's at
your team in every way so I sat down I
did a lot of research I talked to a lot
of my friends and the thing that shocked
me was when I started bringing it up
with friends so many of them especially
entrepreneurs had lots to say lots so
I'll fast forward to what happened when
we had my girlfriend at the time we sat
down we had a really serious meeting
like we actually had a Google agenda we
came with our bullet points and we had a
very adult meeting where we talked about
just the two of you just to us legal
counsel and like that no no we were just
the two of us we talked about you know
when would we like to be engaged and
married where would we live
do we want to have kids so just to be
clear this is a life logistics meeting
and not a prenup meeting that may be
part of it yeah it's a broader
conversation I hadn't even brought the
prenup up yeah okay so we go through you
know kids and and I told her you know I
even mentioned to my wife I said you
know let's talk about the names of our
kids cuz I never saw myself having some
kid named Mike I want Mike running
around in my house and she's like what
the hell where's this coming from
I'm like I just feel particular about
this so so then so we go through the
list and the good news is we were
generally on the same page it's funny
things she goes you know I'd really like
to be engaged by q1 of next year I'm
like oh my god this is the girl of my
dreams she's talking financial quarters
I'm like I love you babe
so so then at the end of that
conversation I said you know there's
something else that's important you know
I it's really important to me that we
discuss a prenup and she was surprised
kind of taken aback she's like okay what
do you mean and I said look you and I
grew up very similar we both grew up in
California our parents have similar jobs
and I said because of certain decisions
I've made because of my business and
because of
a lot of luck I've been put in this
fortunate position where I have a
business and I've accumulated a certain
amount of assets I said it's really
important for me that we talk about what
that means before we get married
and that we sign an agreement in the
worst case if something bad happened and
this was really I was nervous very
nervous because like what what is
someone's reaction gonna be I have no
idea but I thought if anything is gonna
be bad but I felt very I was nervous but
I also felt confident cuz it was
something that I knew that I wanted to
do like it was really important to me so
to her credit she said you know what I'm
surprised I didn't expect it but I'm
open to it
let me get educated about it and we can
talk okay great so that was as good of a
response as I could have hoped she goes
off and she does her own research
she talks to her friends and we start
discussing more and more right we've got
about four or five months until I
proposed to her we start talking the
next step is to get lawyers now
interestingly you have to retain counsel
each side has to retain counsel and
oftentimes what happened is the person
who has more assets will actually pay
for the other person's lawyer which I
did these lawyers are very expensive
right
so I said you know what I'll take care
of that I'm happy to do it
so she found her own lawyer and we start
to go through hammering these basic
terms out now the basic structure of a
prenup is most people don't need a
prenup because most people are coming
into a marriage with relatively similar
assets the places where it starts to
make sense or if you have some major
amount of assets whether it be a house
whether it be an inheritance a business
those kinds of things it starts to make
sense to think about I had to get site
intellectual property yeah absolutely I
had to get comfortable with the idea
that this wasn't a bad thing I wasn't
planning for us to fail and that's the
most common objection people have to
prenups which is you're planning for it
to go wrong
I'm not planning for it to go wrong I
intend to be married forever I want to I
always emphasize that with my wife and I
made it clear that we're a team but I
also mentioned that I've for whatever
reasons I've accumulated these things
and it's really important for me to plan
for what might happen as we talk to more
and more about it it became even more
and more clear that in every other part
of life
top performers plan they plan ahead they
plan for good they plan for bad they
plan but it's like just in this one
situation of life that society has told
everyone no that's wrong you shouldn't
plan at all you should go into it like a
dough with you know these dough eyes and
you shouldn't really think even for a
moment about what would happen if
something goes wrong I mean you get on
an airplane they give you a safety
briefing they don't it's not because
they expect the plane to crash into the
water
that's great exactly it's also a place
just to jump in where it's I've thought
a good amount about this just
relationships and marriage in generals
that when you get married in official
capacity you are involving the state in
your affairs you are signing up for
certain contractual agreements and so in
in any well-planned
agreement you're going to have
contingencies for what happens if things
do not work out there's going to be a
termination clause you're gonna have
that a publishing agreement you're gonna
have that in any number of dozens or
hundreds of other contracts you will
sign will always have a separation
clause the reason why this go this is
such a heated topic for people I think
there's two reasons one there's just a
general ignorance of prenups because it
is inherently a private affair
inherently when you have assets being
discussed it happens behind closed doors
specifically lawyers closed doors it's
not public there are no good guides or
no ebooks on how to do a prenup there's
nothing there's not even any sample
prenups out there they're very very poor
quality the second thing is it attacks
our belief that
in America a marriage is purely about
love and I believe a marriage is
absolutely about love but go look at any
parents or any couple that has let's say
kids go look at them and look at their
day to day yes there's love but there's
also teamwork there's this person's
doing dinner this person's taking the
trash out this person's changing the
diapers it's an arrangement it's a team
and on any team you have to have a set
of rules and so I got comfortable with
that saying you know what this is a love
marriage we found each other we met each
other we love each other but it's also
we want to make sure that this is a team
and we're setting expectations so we
went through the process and we talked
to our lawyers and the lawyers are
hammering it out and this is where it
started to get really tough everything
was going great but then once you
everything's great in concept and then
you talk about real numbers what are the
if I'm a like so what's what are the
basic terms that you're agreeing upon in
a prenup the first thing is you're
laying out all the assets that each
person has yeah those could be assets
liabilities you kind of put those out
out on the table by the way that was a
good conversation that we had I forgot
to take my own advice about when to talk
about money with your partner so my wife
had asked me years ago to help her with
some 401k thing and I was like yeah I'll
help you but first read my book
so she reads my book and then she was
like okay I still have this one question
so we went through it and I got to
understand her pay and and all that
stuff and it was great like we worked
through it like a year or two later she
said you know I feel a little unbalanced
because you know everything about my
finances but I don't know anything about
yours
and that was when I realized like I had
made a huge mistake
I by not telling her I had put myself in
a very unbent placed in an unbalanced
position she's not fair so that
afternoon we talked about it and we
talked about my net worth we talked
about what it means for us and that was
I would say one of
my most pleasant conversations most
pleasant yeah because we talked about
what does it mean for us like our our
rich life now what does it mean and it
means that when we travel we can take
our parents with us and we can spend
extra for them to stretch their legs out
we can travel to places or we can make
certain investments or take risks that
we might not normally be able to do
again as a team so that was actually one
of my favorite memories of talking about
money in the early days now we had
listed out all our assets and
liabilities and now the basic structure
of a prenup is what happens in the case
of the marriage ending and there are so
many ways to cut it know - prenups are
alike what happens if the marriage ends
in three months at an extreme in many
cases a cheque is written
can you believe that if a marriage ends
in three months somebody might write a
check to the other person why just like
pure goodwill severance pay you could
call it that yeah and then both partners
might still have a job etc but what
happens if the marriage now ends you
know 30 years later let's say there's
two or three kids let's say that one
partner has stopped their job so that he
or she can take care of the kids well
it's kind of fair that that person
should be compensated in some way
because it would be unfair for somebody
to walk out of the marriage with just
this large amount of relative assets and
the other person left with nothing
that's just not fair it's not fair in my
eyes personally and it's not fair in the
state size either in in each of these
cases or in most prenups is it a lump
one-time payment or is it like an
ongoing and new annuity that gets paid
each year was a great question yeah what
does it look like it can be decided
however you like but each lawyer is
going to argue for their size so the
person who would be receiving the
payments is going to want it all upfront
right right and so there are also other
questions about what if you're living in
a house with kids and the marriage ends
who leaves how soon that has to be
dictated right and and then there are
other questions about what happen is
there a cap on how much can be paid out
and that's important to understand
though a couple of things the money that
I'm gonna speak generally now the money
that is earned when you are together is
generally community property right so
when you are married
generally the money that is earned is
together it's yours there are certain
exceptions like if you have a business
there's this in that and you can kind of
carve those out ahead of time but in
general we're talking about money that
was accumulated before the marriage
that's really important to understand
kids are definitely a complicating
factor but you are not really dictating
the terms of child of what's it called
custody custody custody and also
payments the state will determine that
so that's really important to know as
well you can't come up with a rule right
now that says you know if we have three
kids and this marriage ends like I'm
gonna write you a check for $1 or 1
million dollars a month that can't work
the state will decide based on lifestyle
let's use a question just from from my
perspective
yeah why get married at all what what is
this because I did really dislike and
this is something that I talk about
usually in the first few dates I mean I
have a great girlfriend right now but
like is like once we've covered like
what do you want for your amount your
main course pretty quickly the subject
comes up is like yep marriage not keen
on having yes some bureaucracy involved
in my relationship it's a great question
and also it's like if you're coming into
a relationship where the current
trajectory of earnings is is vastly
disproportionate the idea of having a
bureaucracy involved and having sort of
everything past a certain day become
community property doesn't have a whole
lot of appeal to me so it were your
reasons for getting married your desire
your partner's desire your families
multiple families expectations or their
other reasons that's a great question
and I think only in this day and age can
this question really be asked because as
recently as 25 years ago this question
would have never been asked it would be
of course you're going to get married
and now you and I both know plenty of
people who are either single or in
cohabitating relationships or casual or
whatever the case may be and they're
perfectly happy not being married I
think for me the answer is probably all
the above it was a desire on my part a
desire on my wife's part and also our
families yeah and this might be an
invisible script from my childhood yeah
that I always saw myself as married so
there's a lot there what the way I
thought about it was I love my wife I
love when we're together she makes me a
better person and I think I do the same
and together as a team we are like
amazing like I love laughing with her I
love how she challenges me and I want to
deepen that relationship the financial
part of it for me was a part that I
wanted to address but I also felt
confident knowing that we could solve it
yeah that we could come to an agreement
and I didn't see it as adversarial at
least until the middle part which I want
to tell you about okay but but I
approached it like very much like can do
yeah it's like hiring someone like I'm
gonna make him an offer I want to make
him a great offer and I expect that
we're gonna have some back-and-forth but
overall it's about coming to an
agreement that we can both work in a
capacity together now I know that sounds
a bit unromantic for a marriage but I'm
talking about the financial part of the
marriage there's a whole there's so many
different layers and we in America only
talk about love what I'm trying to share
is like there are lots of other parts
like be aware of it don't put your head
in the sea you're also talking about
you're not talking about marriage as a
concept you're talking about the
contract of marriage and if you get
married whether you go down to you know
the whatever it might be a blanking on
the term but like some office downtown
to get rubber-stamped like you're
entering into a contract with multiple
parties yeah and so you can enter into a
very nebulous contract or you can enter
into a very clear contract I always say
for every major purchase in your life
every major purchase in every major
decision spend the time most of us
should spend less time on most decisions
and we should spend a lot more time on a
few key decisions like I want to take
this seriously so did my wife so we did
we spent months right so now here we are
the lawyers are going back and forth and
it's starting to get a bit slow like
they're arguing and now we're talking
about it and it became stressful and at
some points like pretty heated okay
and I was like I mean there are so many
things that happen during this time one
we would just stop talking about it for
like weeks at a time because it was just
too stressful and we had never had these
kind of conversations before about money
and like my perspective was like I've
thought about money for 15 or 20 years
every day like this is my business and
I'm really proud of what I've
accomplished financially and I've met
and I always love to come and like I
made a very fair very fair offer bending
over backwards
that was my perspective my wife's
perspective was very different and I
think that I didn't listen as much as I
should I was like IIIi came out I did
this I made this offer and she would say
something and I would say like look at
the spreadsheet like the the look at the
numbers and she was like yeah but and
she was talking about something else in
a completely different language and I
was so preoccupied with like mr.
spreadsheet guy so finally she said you
know we got to go talk to somebody about
this we should go see a therapist and I
was like yeah we really should I totally
agreed with her so you might wonder like
where do you go to find a therapist and
for us the answer was Yelp
we literally opened up Yelp and typed
like therapist and we found one two
blocks away so that's how it's done guys
and we walked over there and we sat down
in this room and we had a conversation
like we've never had before this
therapist was very good she asked us
about how we grew up with money what it
meant and it turns out it meant totally
different things to us like for me it
meant being proud of what I've
accomplished it meant all the work and
for anyone who's built anything you know
the sacrifices it took to build that you
look back you can remember Friday nights
where you didn't go out or you can
remember X or Y or risks you took and I
was seeing that and what my wife was
seeing was something different money
meant something different to her and
this therapist helped us kind of bring
that up and we find ourselves you know
we went one two three sessions we found
ourselves talking about our childhood
and I it's kind of like a caricature
like a joke
of what you talk about in therapy
session but we walked out of each of
those sessions like wow that was that
was pretty good that was pretty helpful
so we still were having the lawyers go
back and forth but now we were
connecting more with each other
financially and we we were reminded by
this therapist like we're a team this is
just an agreement we need to come to but
remember why you are together remember
why you're getting married we finally
came to an agreement and we signed it
and it's funny because one of my buddies
he held an event called like should you
sign a prenup and he invited like 20 or
25 people right and one of his friends
who was married and had done a prenup
sent him a note and said I'd rather be
dead than come to this event and he was
like whoa whoa why and he's like dude
that was the worst six months of my life
imagine you have someone you love and
you're arguing about money with lawyers
for six months and I didn't get that
until I'd gone through it I would say
that in retrospect I learned a couple of
things number one I should have talked
about money with my wife way earlier
like way earlier I violated my own
advice and that was horrible I should
have talked about it earlier
- I should have stopped being mr.
spreadsheet dude and actually listened
and said like let's put the numbers
aside and talk about what money means
for me like I told you I'm proud of it
my wife wanted to feel safe she wanted
to know that if anything went wrong that
she would be taken care of and that and
I didn't really internalize what that
meant to her like what does that mean I
should have listened I should have gone
to see a therapist earlier and we should
have not let it stretch out for as long
as it did
that was really torturous for both of us
how would you have expedited it Wow
therapy earlier well I mean that's why
I'm here that's what I want to share
with people don't just hope that it will
kind of work itself out over time it's
everybody involved in the process wants
it to stretch out the lawyers they're
not trying to just bill you more but
they're incentive is to get you the best
deal and the other lawyers to get the
other one
you have to take control and manage the
process but both of you have to be
aligned on that I would have yet
definitely talked to a therapist ahead
of time with my wife we would have gone
there together faster and we kind of
would have I would have started off not
talking about money but like rather
about meaning that and that's something
that I'm hoping to be able to talk more
about but I hope from people listening
to this if you go in and you've got a
spreadsheet that you want to discuss
you've taken a wrong turn that's what I
did I should have talked about meaning
and fears and hopes about money as
opposed to like let's go through the
numbers the numbers are like the last
part I was gonna say it's not either/or
right it's it's sequencing both end and
you got to talk about the numbers but
once you get meaning aligned the numbers
work themselves out so when we've
chatted about this it's been passing in
the past because I wanted to make sure
we did on the podcast yeah a couple of
stories have come up that I'm not sure
how to grapple with now I'm at a point
also where I haven't had conversations
with attorneys about this type of thing
although I mean it makes sense to think
about estate planning yeah whether your
estate is small medium
more large it makes a lot of sense to
think about that and things can be
really messy speaking as someone who had
grandparents who didn't think about
anything and we're not you know rolling
it doing backstroke and a pool full of
coins like Scrooge McDuck but
nonetheless when emotions are heated
kids can fight over anything even if
it's just table scraps and that was a
mess I don't want that to ever affect if
I have kids to affect my kids so yep you
should think about earlier but the point
I was gonna make is I haven't gone
through the actual drafting of say a
prenup and but I've seen marriages
implode and like the the the numbers if
you just like let's try to coldly
objectively look at the numbers in the
u.s. they're not that hot so it makes
make sense to plan whether it's like
driving about the seatbelt in your car
like you're not planning on getting
accident but you want to be covered if
you do I've heard horrible stories right
so I've heard stories of friend who had
a prenup went through all the same
process and then I think it was a week
after he got married or Shore or just
before he got married his wife to be
your wife said I signed the prenup under
duress oh my god I don't I don't feel
good about it and it was back to the
table that under duress for people who
don't know is and this is not a legal
definition but under extreme stress
therefore the position of the person
who's claiming dress is that the
contract is invalid because you they
were pressured into it and this can
apply to quite a few contracts it turns
out and he was he was in a position
where he had to go back and it was
renegotiated and the numbers changed so
like the lump payments and so on were
changed and so that's that's
fear-inducing that's scary you could
have an agreement and then end up in a
situation like that right and the point
number one whether it's legally forced
upon you or just practically day-to-day
you're like well where the [ __ ] do we go
from here and have to then step back
into like negotiation mode and I've also
heard of approaches I'm not saying maybe
this is getting too much into like the
dark arts or something but we're friends
have thought like alright if if I'm
going to if I'm trying to defend against
the worst case scenario would it make
sense for me to go engage X number of
very high caliber divorce attorneys
they're conflicted out if we end up
having a divorce later like that's a
that's a little Voldemort but I can also
see the practicality of it so like how
do you think about what landmines you
might need to avoid if there are any
right like yeah it's a big question but
it's like this [ __ ] gets messy you know
I would say that I've spoken to a lot of
different attorneys both in in getting
married but also as a CEO and one of
them told me something really
interesting they said that the people
with the lawyers with the most
interesting stories are criminal lawyers
of course the second most interesting
lawyer stories are workplace attorneys I
would be willing to bet that the third
is divorce attorneys because the stories
are just like out of this world I didn't
really approach it like that to tell you
the truth I I didn't plan on the
marriage ending I simply wanted to
account for what might happen
financially so let me put it this way if
at the point where you're sort of
already thinking about like let me
engage all these divorce attorneys which
I don't even know if that works or not
I've heard it's a rumor but like I feel
like there's a larger problem going on
there a much larger problem these
lawyers are not stupid they're all very
good they've seen it all and and the
thing is to negotiate in good faith you
have to remember you're not trying to
get one over on your partner you're if
you were just trying to get one over
like a car dealer you're trying to
maximize it cuz it's a one-time
transaction this is the partner you're
gonna be with for the rest of your life
so that actually necessitates a
different way of negotiating like when I
was discussing with my attorney and that
attorney was negotiating with my wife's
attorney I had to compromise on things
that I normally would not compromise on
and that just to put it bluntly like I
haven't had to compromise financially in
the last 25 years right at all
yeah so suddenly I'm like what what is
this taste in my mouth I haven't tasted
this taste of compromising bile
yeah it's but but that's why I think
it's really important a couple
principles came up for me one is go slow
to go fast I should have done a better
job of this of like let's talk about the
meaning with the meaning right go slow
to go fast and the second one was always
remember the North Star the North Star
here is not getting an extra dollar or
protecting the extra two dollars it's
we're gonna be married day to day for
the rest of our lives
that's the North Star and like putting
that in perspective like as the lawyers
saying this or that I had to constantly
remind myself so did my wife and by the
way I just want to say she was excited
for me to come here and talk about this
she actually encouraged me because I
wrote about it in my book I wrote some
more details and I asked her I said are
you okay if I share this and we talked
about it
we both realized going through this that
both of us were pretty alone no one was
talking about this publicly and we're
both big fans you know she's a stylist I
do what I do
we love shining the light on things that
people are not really talking about
publicly because we're both very curious
and we both want to get better so if she
had said no I would have never written
this stuff I would have never come on
here and talked about this but she
actually said yes go on there and tell
them our experience because other people
should know this whether you do it or
not you should know all right
I've questions so this is gonna be a
super awkward one made for me to ask
more than for you to answer because
you're being put on the spot but I'm the
one who has the option of asking
whatever I want so this is something
I've seen so many people struggle with
what I'm about to bring up and I want to
hear if it affected you and if so how
you used mental jiu-jitsu or
contortionism to get through it and that
is if you're coming into a negotiation
say for a prenup and you are the person
who is bringing in disparate
the assets and income and that could be
not necessarily a 51/49 split right I
mean this could be like a 90/10 split 99
1 split and it very often is I mean it
can very often be when you're looking at
the settlement and the amount right so
it's very hard for someone let's just
say who's made ten thousand dollars a
year to ever imagine what it really
means and what it takes to make a
hundred thousand ditto if someone's
making like fifty grand a year what does
it mean in terms of sacrifice and
planning and like Friday's missed and
weekend's worked and holiday skipped to
make a million dollars right and so all
of a sudden then you're going through a
negotiation where someone who has
perhaps not made a decade or two decades
of sacrifice is asking for an amount
that is more than you made in the first
thirty years of your life how do you
navigate that because there's like
viscerally I know a lot of people and
I'm one of them who's just like that
makes no sense and it also brings up
like well wait a second if that's the
amount that gets paid out I would start
questioning the sort of motives of the
other person it's like okay well they
were able to kind of do whatever they
want for X period of time but now if we
get divorced three years from now
they're set for life if they don't screw
it up how do you I would that would make
me feel very uncomfortable to me too I
mean I think remember when I said that
like I was proud of what I had
accomplished and you go through so many
emotions in this process and the funny
thing is when it comes to money I'm not
emotional at all like day-to-day I'm
super I call it hot to cool I think most
people or some people particularly those
in debt money is like a phantom or a
gremlin it's a beast that they're
fighting right they need to break the
shackles of this debt I've overcome
those things to me it's a tool and I use
it for convenience things like that so
to find myself going from
nervousness in bringing this up to be
pride that I wanted to talk about the
numbers and I was very proud of what I
had accomplished and what it meant for
us and then resentment you know I
definitely felt resentful because you
know to me I'm like look at the
spreadsheet like I have gone above and
beyond and like how can you not
acknowledge that I found myself like
experiencing these emotions I hadn't
honestly ever felt about money and and I
think that's where a therapist helped me
but I should have done it sooner cuz it
really was not healthy to just sort of
soak in them for literally months and
remember we're like seeing each other
day to day and so that definitely
affects you as you're planning a wedding
with your partner you can sequence it
out you're like don't do that you know I
think that it's a question that I don't
have a good answer to I think that the
the basic there are certain things in
life that are just not fair okay and one
of them it might be this but really
that's not the point the point is not
for me to win that's what I learned
along the way at least this is my lesson
some people might think differently my
point in retrospect was not to win this
negotiation it was to win our marriage
meaning both of us get there together as
a team and if I have to compromise a few
things which in business I would never
have made a couple of the compromises I
made but this is more important than my
business right this is the person that
I'm gonna spend my last days with so
that actually really put things in
perspective for me it's like oh [ __ ]
sometimes you learn about yourself just
by observing what you yourself do and I
was like did I really just agree to that
that one 10th term we've been discussing
for a month yes I did
Wow like my wife is that important to me
and I realize like yes she is so I don't
know I don't have a good answer for you
on that but I'll tell you I really swung
emotions I felt resentful and I hate
feeling resentful it's one of the most
toxic emotions but I think there's
something larger than like being right
in this now maybe that's just well I
mean that's I think I think cutting off
your nose to spite your face to be right
doesn't make sense yeah I also think
that it's possible to play not to lose
or set yourself up for blind spots why
all not at all costs trying to win 100
right right like don't be an [ __ ] and
like make a bunch of insistent demands
based on principle that don't
practically make sense is fair but
walking into something blind and just
offering yourself as a pinata yeah
doesn't make sense either okay you know
what's crazy about this whole thing now
so once you sign it like it's done
in fact in at least in our case we're
like all right thank God we don't want
to look at this now like file it away
good the real challenge actually since
we got married just about a year ago has
been like day-to-day spending and that
now using the tools we learn from this
therapist and also going slow to go fast
like my dream okay my fantasy was to
have this just beautiful financial model
okay that's what I wanted like this
model that we look at and everything's
like going from side to side we've built
that it's taken like eight or nine
months what what I realize now is
emotions first what does it mean who's
cooking dinner who's taking the trash
out let's get all that stuff done the
model part is like the last part of it
and because we had these tough
conversations earlier on now we're like
okay let's let's start with the emotions
we have buffers so if we overspend a
little bit on eating out right now
that's okay we'll dial in the numbers
later like what I've realized is the
numbers really come last and so we are
both really thankful we went through the
process although I wish we could have
been I wish you could have had some
guidance really but funny enough though
once you sign it it's not like you're
reviewing it every single day yeah
you're it's the day to day now it's
literally the littlest things like who's
picking up X at the store
you know that's where day-to-day
financial stuff comes in and that's
another area where I think you use the I
will teach you to be rich stuff the
system's the
idea that you don't really want to be
spending your valuable cognition on like
who's buying deodorant or rice like have
a system automate it boom we were
talking about what spend a lot of time
on it but your relative who you thought
was 65 you and your wife thought was 65
or something it ended up being 87 and
uncle's and how regimented regiment is
the wrong word how much of his life is
is routinized right it wakes up at the
same time and we are just grabbing
coffee earlier and I said I wonder how
much of his longevity is that lifetime
accumulation of avoiding decision
fatigue on [ __ ] that just shouldn't
consume your brain every day at all so I
believe just like you have a playbook I
believe in a playbook for life here's a
couple playbook rules that I have one I
call it row meets book buying rule if
you ever see a book you're even remotely
interested in buy it don't debate it
don't ask if it's the second best just
buy it it's ten dollars is the best
money you ever spent have a year of cash
have it available liquid and if you
don't have it build up to it save up for
big expenses engagement ring wedding
honeymoon all that stuff house sub
accounts sub accounts boom when I eat at
a restaurant now my joy is if I see
anything that looks good I just order it
and I also tell the people eating with
me do the same don't even think about it
and so like my co-workers loved eating
out with me because I'm like disorder at
all like I got the bill just a quick
side note for anyone who has not seen it
it came out not long ago from the time
of this recording but there's an
incredible ESPN article on coach Gregg
Popovich and the dinners and the wine
for the Spurs it is phenomenal fantastic
people can look that up they have a
couple of areas in your life where you
have absolutely no budget it doesn't
matter how much you spend you just love
it unlimited unlimited there's no if you
love strawberries like when I grew up I
loved strawberries but we had a big
family and strawberries were expensive
there is no amount of strawberries that
will ever cause me any material
difference in my life
it's three bucks four bucks 5 bucks 6
bucks doesn't matter buy it have
something it could be as small as
strawberries it could be as big as
whatever eat the same for this is for me
personal a lot of people don't agree but
eat the same thing mostly the same thing
every single day I do it it's just easy
decision fatigue I do the same thing
yeah and then also so this is what my
wife and I've been talking about
recently is let's come up with some
rules for our relationship - these are
guidelines we can change him but you
know we were planning a vacation we're
gonna stay with a friend for their
birthday in Mexico City and we're
looking at flights and I find that we're
deciding which flight should it be
economy should it be business what hotel
this or that and I said like hey let's
let's get into it let's kind of figure
out where we like to travel together in
what style but over the course of the
next few months let's kind of come up
with some basic rules for example if
you're traveling over five hours
business class or if we're staying just
the two of us we don't need a fancy
hotel whatever the case make a basic
guideline so that we don't have to think
about it all the time
and even down to like who's taken out
the trash like let's just kind of
articulate that and be explicit so that
it's all on the table and that way it
clears up any misconceptions so I love
this general playbook for life
especially what's this what was your
conclusion on the trash oh dude I take
the trash out okay and it just got
revealed because like I would notice the
trash filling up and then she would take
it out once in a while but really she
would say like would you mind taking the
trash out and it just became very clear
in any relationship there are certain
things that one person does or doesn't
like to do and like the same thing true
for cooking ironing clothes yeah Cass
cooks my iron quick note on that one
thing that I've found really helpful is
whether it's with friends or your
significant other but especially
significant other is agreeing in advance
from a scale of 1 to 10 10 being
absolutely heartfelt must have or must
not have you can't use a lot of tents
like so that you only really get a
couple of tens in your pockets so don't
spend them on nonsense right but asking
someone like zero to like 1 to 10 how
much do you like doing this or 1 to 10
how much do you hate doing this and it's
like all right if to you it's like you
don't love taking out the garbage but if
it's
I'm a five out of ten like six out of
ten who cares like it doesn't really
matter she's like I grew up in such a
such a way I hate taking out the garbage
like okay fine I'll take out the car
wait so what's your ten on liking or not
liking let's go both so I for instance
very fond of cooking very unfund of
cleanup love it right lassic yeah and
what about something you hate well
something I hate would be the cleanup
okay other things I hate would be for
instance I and much happier to pay for
things if I can avoid decisions so if my
partner is willing to handle logistics
we went to Burning Man it was her first
time and I knew what I was signing up
for and I told her I was like I will go
but only if you handle the logistics I
will pay for everything but in terms of
like getting costumes and like getting
everything there and the bikes and the
lights and the but that thought the
thought that uh you need to be like this
the CEO of this operation and I'm happy
to be like controller her approves the
checks love it but that's it got it
so I love that you're explicit and I
love that 1 to 10 I have to think about
that I've overheard my wife talking to
her parents and I grew up with my mom
cooking food for us every night right
every night like right off the stove she
would be giving us rotis or whatever she
was making and we all ate together as a
family and I really loved that so every
night my wife will either make food or
it'll she'll have cooked it a couple
times and then she'll bring it to me and
like that is so meaningful to me because
it reminds me of my childhood and by the
way the the food that we eat is
extremely inexpensive like we're not
getting the fanciest cuts of meat we
don't care about that but it's carefully
we track all of our macros and all that
stuff so we care about that but really
it's about the meaning behind it
macros 4p blue tone of fat protein
carbohydrate yeah the percentages of
each what does the pie chart look like
the I don't know the math off the top of
my head but it's like every week it
changes depending on whatever my goals
are and like I think the meaning there
is really important and then there's
certainty
forecast that you know she likes or she
doesn't like and I'll do trash is a
perfect example I just kind of
discovered like she really doesn't like
taking the trash up no problem it's easy
for me to take it out so getting those
on the same page and developing this
just life playbook of general rules of
thumb you're going to use especially for
stuff that's not important man that
really frees you up to to really get
into the stuff that is important yeah
for sure so I I know we don't have too
much time left but I want to jump into
one of these because I'm curious what
what you will say in response to some of
these questions and we may only have
time for one or two but so these are
from people on the interwebs always a
risky proposition but they were they
were voted on or up voted and won this
is from Scott no last name here
indicated weirdoes for me disagree with
what Tim teaches or preaches or Brian
and I'll just rephrase that but like
what do you think we disagree on this is
a good question it could be anything
right but far away oh my god I love this
I think that we disagree on morning
routines yeah I think they're overrated
you know I think that the best morning
routine is decided a year ago it's about
your psychology it's about how much you
sleep it's about what you know what have
you outlined in your calendar it's all
those softer details and I think that
you know I get people asking me every
day what's my morning routine and I'm
like who gives a [ __ ] like you think you
think if I ask Michael I'm not saying
I'm Michael Jordan at all but if I ask
Michael Jordan what shoes he wears or
what his morning routine is am I going
to be like Mike no and similarly if you
find out what kind of coffee I drink
you're not gonna be doing what I do
either but I know that you're not saying
that but that's what people are taking
away that drives me insane well yeah I
mean what keep was correct the record in
one person tries to impart and what
people here are sometimes very different
thanks for yeah right the gift that
keeps on giving
still morning routines I think are
number number one for me coming back to
what we just said morning routines are
one example of removing decisions that's
it
there's a little bit more to it for me
in the sense that as someone who had
onset insomnia and slept very poorly for
several decades I would wake up and be
non-functional generally speaking so
having a boot up sequence which didn't
require any thought I'm not deciding
what to eat for breakfast I'm not
deciding what step number one is do I do
a b c d or e first no I'm always going
to be doing be right well a whatever it
might be has been very helpful I also
know equally or far more successful
people who have your answer they're like
I wake up I drink a [ __ ] cup of
coffee i reaiize know Instagram first
literally the first thing I do is I get
on Instagram while I'm in bed it's like
the worst possible thing but I'm like I
like it yeah and it's all cabins it's
all cabins I swear to god the the the
question I think that is that is also
just like a macro questions worth asking
is is this person you're looking at
succeeding because of or despite what
you're looking at right this is really
important it's especially important if
you're studying people who have already
reached escape velocity in some type of
success or financial freedom and you are
still working your way up because
hindsight is not 20/20 a lot of folks
who are on top of the world and are just
crafting billion dollar deals every day
do not remember very clearly what helped
them when they were working in the
office on Thanksgiving or whatever might
have been this is a great point and so
powerful by the way this is why I love
your podcast because here we are two
people who seemingly disagree on
something but now we're getting into the
nuances and we can really cracked a code
of what's what's the differences in
similarities I will totally agree with
what you just said about the more
successful you get or the more time you
get away from something
the less details you remember I'll give
you an example my wife started she used
to be a senior buyer Equinox
she left to start her own styling
business about 18 months ago I would
hear her doing sales calls in our living
room and I would see her sometimes
closing a client and sometimes going
weeks without closing a client and you
know I've got a business now I've got
amazing employees we've got traffic
that's coming you know we've got people
coming and regular customers and all
that stuff but when I started off that
[ __ ] was not easy I would go weeks
without getting one person joining any
of my programs and I forgot how
emotional it is you're the highs are so
high and the lows are so low and half
the game in this is just living to fight
another day he's just not giving up and
improving just a tiny bit every day and
I watched it and I heard her and I saw
her go through the ups and that lows and
it's amazing now this month she told me
how many clients she's done she's
totally booked up for two or three more
months it's amazing what she's
accomplished in eighteen months she
never would have believed it
but you forget and you forget fast the
tiniest details of what it means to wake
up in the morning and say like wow the
last four weeks I haven't gotten one
client am I gonna do it different today
so I just big shout out to every
entrepreneur who's starting out out
there it's tough and you should always
put in context the advice that you hear
and thanks for bringing it up because
people need to know it's not all roses
like [ __ ] is hard when you start it's
hard for everyone it actually should be
hard but if you stick with it hopefully
you're doing the right thing you can get
escape velocity so morning routines one
thing we have somewhat differing
approaches to what else tools I think
that tools are super valuable people
love to talk about tools but you know
you give Andre Agassi a wooden racket
he's gonna kick my ass so I think like
when you ask well if somebody asked me
like what apps do I use like my apps are
horrible I don't use I use like TripIt
that's it it's but I think the more
powerful things
are the psychology are the systems which
are run through a Google Doc that's my
take on tools and and so that's those
are my two areas of disagreement curious
to hear what you think about the tools
and also if you disagree with me on
anything
well I provide a lot of tools because I
think the specifics are helpful but it's
the reasoning behind it I would imagine
we're probably on the same page with and
that is the tools are byproducts of
principles or strategies right so for
instance I use TripIt - I think it's
underrated yeah but people are like ok
great I'm gonna go you strip it and
that's gonna be grand it's like well yes
but maybe but what are the principles
behind it and it's it's so that I can
avoid manual checking of things like
gate updates it's so that I'm avoiding a
certain decision certain manual
activities that are being automated
right it's so that I don't have to go I
don't have to go to Google or wherever
on my phone and search fill-in-the-blank
airline check-in yeah because I can
click a button and trip it and do it
automatically whether it's Delta United
American whatever all rights the end in
that principle if you were to pull it
back will be will then allow you to
deduce which tools to use or at least
ask people for the right tools but it's
it's it's very easy to believe they're
like oh wow
so-and-so is a great player so-and-so is
a great business person so-and-so is a
great artist because they use
watercolors it's like no whether it's
watercolors oil Conte crayons doesn't
matter
charcoal graphite you need to know the
technique and the principles behind it
and the process then you can choose your
tools yeah I think it's easy to become a
tool fetishist
without understanding why you're doing
what you're doing and then you become
kind of like where is it Solomon Islands
where they have the cargo cult or they
have like the fake runways and the fake
towers and it's like okay great you have
flown full of the greatest apps like
you've got 79 different rules for email
filtering and guess what you didn't do
one [ __ ] important thing today so
okay I agree with you on that I think
that's really good and I think the way
you articulated
deduce what TripIt what the principles
behind you using TripIt are is critical
I do the same thing we use it for the
same reasons but I also take that same
principle and apply it to what I do in
the morning and how I decide what place
to meet someone for coffee all that
stuff has been automated so I don't have
to think about it ever again
so that's a good point yeah and I would
say also that it is possible very
possible and actually very common to
procrastinate by searching for
incrementally better and better tools oh
I do that all the time and I could do
the vast majority of what I do with like
a day planner yeah and in fact I think
the finite nature this is why I still
use paper
I still use note cards or small pieces
of paper for to-do lists and things like
that because it is it is by its very
nature finite I cannot have a list of 37
things I need to do so the in some
respects I think applying constraints to
the tools that you use in the same way
that I had Neil Gaiman actually sitting
right where you are on this podcast not
too long ago and he uses very often a
fountain pen and pads of paper for
drafting and it sounds very romantic and
it is in some respects but it also has a
number of psychological and practical
benefits but it seems very primitive
it's not the the latest cutting-edge
tool all right I love it that's a great
explanation of the nuances behind tools
yeah so yeah I appreciate that and it's
also easy I think for us like we could
disagree on tools all day long
right I mean we could we could disagree
on the implementation of various things
but here's here's I think one
observation that is important that is
you and I are not the same person
meaning like like you like you like
fancy sweaters I'm wearing an $8 t-shirt
that my mom got me right yeah and like
these pants and these shoes were both
given to me and I'm not wearing socks
and so we have different desires your
vacation may look differently from mine
your family
India is different from my family on the
east coast of you know this country and
that's all fine that's great
and it also means that the way we
approach problem solving is going to be
different yeah
that's a really good point and that but
the principles a lot of the principles I
I do think are very similar or like the
values and the principles are similar
otherwise I don't think we would have
been friends for as long as we have
totally agree and I think there's a
there's value in the diversity of how we
think there's also value in knowing that
those will change over time right so as
I've gotten married I'm like oh wow
there's this whole world I didn't
understand before and now I'm learning
that and I'm growing with my wife I
think as we've gotten in relationships
we've talked about how that's changed us
Wow
and that's like a pretty interesting
topic and then you know if we had like
if we had anybody else here who maybe
didn't look like us or if we they
weren't our gender we had all different
kinds of diversity opinions we would
have even more ways of thinking about
how we approach problems and I think
what I have learned along the way like
when I wrote the book for example I was
a bit judgmental about what the rich
life was in the first edition I was like
this is how you should invest follow the
principles and like this is where you
end up now ten years later there's a lot
of people in the fire community for
example that's financial independence
retire early and many people are happy
to acquire enough to basically be able
to live on 30k a year live a very simple
life and if they want to have a fun
afternoon maybe they'll go to the park
and they're like we don't need
materialistic stuff we're happy and back
then I think I would have been pretty
judgmental about it now I've realized
look there's lean fire there's fat fire
there's all kinds of different fire and
some people don't want a fire in fact
most Americans will never fire they will
work until they're of retirement age but
rich life looks different to different
people and part of that comes from how
were we raised where what do our parents
tell us and then part of it is do we
want to change that story or do we want
to just go with that
question about retirement I was gonna
ask this earlier so this
I mean I've you know wrote about this as
far back as is my equally scammy
sounding book 4-hour workweek a thousand
years ago but the this is concept of
retirement right let's replace that with
financial freedom because I want to ask
you what that means or what you how you
think people should think about it
because a lot of thinking about
retirement I find to be extremely porous
at best like it's it's very faulty and
well you're in your book you had a great
example of mini retirements and like you
want to buy a Ferrari why don't you just
rent it for a week yeah great exam or
you think like okay 20 years from now
everything I'm doing is predicated on
being able to like buy a boat and I'm
gonna live on my boat and sail around
the Mediterranean for 20 years after
that's like maybe you should get on a
boat first yes and try that for a
weekend like go take a sailing course
you might come out of being like that
[ __ ] sucks and I was who I felt sick
the entire time okay good to know that
now and not when you've kind of slaved
away and done something that you find
distasteful for 20 years and people mess
up the math too right I mean they often
miss calculate and end up having very
tough time in retirement per se so with
with your students how do you encourage
them to think about the objective right
yeah well I don't believe that most
people are automatons that sit down and
say here's my 50 year goal and let me
break it down in reverse engineer to
what I'm gonna do this week I know about
two people like that and they're special
on their own but most people don't do
that most people are very simple they
want to wake up they want to have a good
day at work maybe they want to have a
little bit of fun or watch Netflix or
have a good conversation with their
partner or their friends and that's a
good day and that's okay now to kind of
push people out of that and make them
think a little bit bigger it might be
taking a vacation they may not have done
it might be going to a tea event that
they may have never thought of going to
it's these experiences that people
remember I would say that your comment
about retirement is really true for
people our age
I don't hear anyone saying like when I
retire this that my pension like those
conversations are not happening with our
generation so there's more of what do I
want to do there's more spending on
things like wellness and vacations and
experiences and we're seeing that in the
economy as well what I tell people is a
couple of things number one you may not
think right now that you want to retire
but when you look at what everybody else
who reaches a certain age does if
everyone does something it might be true
and so plan for it like I don't want to
buy a house but almost everybody else
does so I saved enough for a down
payment I don't need to use it but it's
there if I need to
similarly don't wait right and think
bigger so don't wait means go take a
trip for three days and think bigger is
like your retirement doesn't have to
just be sitting around it can actually
be much bigger that money dial turn it
to ten and it could be traveling with a
fixer it could be going for a month
a year or two months but in order to do
that you need to build a muscle now of
thinking bigger people have this linear
belief that once this bifurcation of
retirement happens then the curtain
opens and I get to do all this cool
stuff dude if you haven't been doing it
until you're 60 years old you're not
going to magically do it at sixty years
old in one day so I would encourage
people to start building the muscle just
like you've told him and realize that
doing creative things trying different
things is a muscle I found myself
getting lazy with this in New York I
looked at where I had gone to in the
city like over the course of the last
six months and I was like I live in this
amazing city and I'm not even taking
advantage of it so I put it into my
calendar once a quarter minimum I'm
gonna do a cultural event like a show or
a tea tasting whatever the case be
something that I could only do in New
York and so now it's like on the
calendar and you can say it sounds
unromantic but I'm like that's what I
needed to do that to keep building my
muscle of trying new things so whatever
works for people do it but I would say
don't wait until you are retirement age
yeah and I feel like so much in our
conversation has come back to you
making one decision that removes a
thousand decisions in the sense that
like you put it in your calendar and for
me if it's not in the calendar it's just
not real right so even what we call
batching conversations for with me and
my girlfriend for discussing certain
like constant not issues in the sense of
problems but like we have a with
regularly scheduled times to talk about
certain things we do the same thing and
it's in the calendar so it's and that's
true with certain types of kind of like
date nights it's true if we're talking
my relationships right it's true for
taking trips together yeah it's true for
visiting my family visiting her family
and by making that decision and putting
it in the calendar you preserve your
brain power and emotional resilience and
so on for other stuff that is less
predictable do you have a consistent
thing you talk about on your check-ins
we do yeah we have a whole format and
everything yeah okay so this is amazing
I love meeting smart people who apply
their intelligence to a different part
of life like for example there's a book
out by Gretchen Rubin who we both know
and she's just so smart and she decided
to write a book about keeping her house
and workspace organized and I'm like yep
bought it and the stuff she writes about
in there is clever interesting it's
exactly what you would think a smart
person applying themselves to something
for like a year would come up with and
the fact that you and your girlfriend
have we call it a touch base or a
check-in and you have a consistency it's
on the calendar like I love that and
yeah you know I want to know like what's
on that how do what what surprised you
did it because we're going through
building our own one and we're tweaking
it and I'm like this is awesome she's
much smarter about anything involving
emotions oh that's funny my wife is the
one who suggested most do much more much
more observant than I am it's like two
cavemen talking yeah
she she's much yeah are we good we're
good okay great like that would be our
chicken we could be [ __ ] good cuz I
don't feel like having this conversation
uh yeah we're good okay great
oh no maybe this will be helpful for
folks we'll spend a few minutes on this
we have a number of rituals and things
in the calendar that I think are
important for the care and nurturing of
the relationship and one a epiphany that
I think we both had at one point was
that a I have a tendency to emotionally
shut off or get defensive with a lot of
questions involving emotion or emotional
vulnerability it's just not something I
was really exposed to growing up yeah I
mean there was or in school or with
coaches I mean really
the feeling was and like I say my family
as a whole but I come from a pretty it's
the right word here stoic and not in the
the cool hip like Marcus are really a
sense but like a fairly stoic like
Protestant like environment we're in
school for instance you know that and in
coaching the general feeling was like
don't tell me the good stuff because the
good stuff takes care of itself like
tell me what needs to be fixed yeah
turns out that's not I've come to
realize the best approach for longevity
in the relationship that I want to have
with my girlfriend and which we tried to
be pointed out to make some why this is
amazing because just think about this
what got you here yeah
something got you here to a very elite
level and it would be easy to just be
like oh my god I'll just keep doing what
I'm doing because I I won that game well
they were playing a different game well
i think that the question i didn't ask
for a very long time is like what did it
cost yes and what what was the
collateral damage wow breaks it's like
yeah the Hulk's a great [ __ ] superhero
he all
[ __ ] mess that's a good one and I
think that there was a lot of collateral
damage that I probably didn't notice and
certainly didn't weigh very heavily
because I was like yeah but look what I
did totally or yeah but look what
happened and it excused a lot of mess
100%
and so she's but the so what we what we
realized after that was pointed out to
me was or what I then said to my
girlfriend because she was curious about
how to better word things so that I
wouldn't have a disproportionate like
emotional response that's cool that she
was curious about that yeah she's very
good at asking questions and probing
because if I think I have a sensitivity
as someone who's effectively worked as a
freelancer for decades that if like I
have my headphones on and I'm in the
middle of like a project I don't want to
stop and have like a five-minute
conversation about something extraneous
it I get I get unnecessarily spun out
over stuff like that and she says well
how should i phrase things so that it's
it's easier and less distracting for you
and and I remember saying is it I said
it has nothing to do with the content
it's all timing and and that was a real
breakthrough for our relationship not
because we had the conversation this is
really [ __ ] important cuz like yeah
you can go to like fill in the blank
seminar you can read fill in the blank
book you can take fill in the blank drug
and have this amazing epiphany and do
nothing with it what we did from that
point was then set up what we call these
batching times once a week or once every
two weeks where we sit down and she has
a chance to talk to me when I am
prepared to talk about things that are
going to make me uncomfortable and she
can handle it whenever she's more
adaptable and resilient in that way but
I can blame it on bringing I can blame
it on being just a weirdo who knows or
just you know if a heteronormative male
who doesn't like talking about [ __ ] who
knows
having that time blocked out where I can
like steal myself and like warm myself
up psychologically to talk about things
that are gonna make me uncomfortable is
very valuable and the format the format
that we currently have so we couldn't
find any real great advice on the same
and the Sephora we have is we will well
we take notes we have like meeting notes
after everyone yeah and it's and where
we capture what in in kind of bullet
points what was said so we start with
one person we'll start and they'll
they'll say what they think they've been
doing well nice and it didn't start out
this way but it ended up they start with
what they think they've been doing well
or doing better then they talk about if
they want where they think they've
dropped the ball or could focus more
which is very helpful for defusing
things because they bring it up them so
yeah then they will they will tell the
other person what they're doing well and
then they'll tell the other person we
started off with like [ __ ] you need to
fix or that was probably my phrasing and
then it was growth opportunities and now
it's what I'd like what I would love to
see more of nice and that the phrasing
turns out to be really important right
so it's like what I think I'm doing well
since we last checked in what I think I
could do better what you're doing well
and then what I'd like to see more oh
yeah and then we take notes and each
then we forward it to the other person
and we can we can take a look at it and
that's that's it amazing then it usually
takes an hour maybe two hours and this
in the morning or in the evening usually
in the afternoon or evening on a weekend
oh okay interest that's most common okay
yeah so the note part is also
interesting so you take notes quickly
saying or she'll know one of us will
take notes on the whole thing okay okay
god there's kind of like one secretary
or or minute keeper for that session
that's cool and so it could be me I take
notes in notebooks a lot so I'd take
notes in a notebook then take a photo in
senator or she'll take it in notepad
Senate it's interesting interesting part
of it too is like each person will have
some skin in the game in terms of
recording it yeah and then I have an
Evernote file where I put all of our
chickens in reverse chronological order
so the most recent is at the top yeah so
I can go back and look and see like
alright did did we and this is not - as
a gotcha it's just like alright did I
keep up my end of the bargain did I say
I was gonna work on something three
weeks ago and then I kind of forgot
about it but also later also not just
from the avoiding bad but doing look
good yeah like you imagine after a year
now you go and you're like oh my god
like we have been super consistent and
like look at the things we used to talk
about and look at the things we're
talking about now yeah the good the the
highlighting what is being done well is
really important and that it's it's so
against every behavior in habit that
I've built over my entire life but I
have come to realize that without that
yeah it can really really be tough so
one of the things that I love about this
first of all thanks for sharing those
Ness super helpful as we are starting
this ritual on our own and I think this
is a great example and by the way my
girl like I my girlfriend did 90% of
that so like I'm along for the ride but
you want to give her proper credit
totally I think that's an example where
the ritual itself may be even more
important than the content yeah the
ritual of having the time having it on
the calendar respecting it always
showing up being mentally present and
tracking it that is like 90% of the
ballgame and that just shows this
awesome mutual respect you both have for
each other and the fact that you take it
seriously and it's not weird to write
down an agenda I think so many people
are they think about things as weird or
weird to have a Google agenda or be
weird to save for an engagement ring I
don't I'm not even dating anyone well I
think it's weird to live life as most
people you know I think that's weird
I would rather plan ahead I would pick
some things I want to do differently and
just be unapologetic about it so I think
it's really cool that you're sharing
that including down to like what are the
questions because I'm gonna take some of
those and take it back to my wife and
we're going to do those it's it's been
it's it's it's really been a big deal
for us
and it like you said I think the the
intention in the act of calendaring it
is is of great value aside from the
implementation right the fact that you
are both setting aside time to keep the
relationship on the rails and to improve
it is in and of itself going to have an
impact on the relationship and there are
times also when we'll put these batching
sessions out well schedule them out and
she's better at this than I am I'm I
could actually find any a gram pretty
helpful even though I'm not convinced
it's more than like business acceptable
astrology basically but in any case any
of them can kind of be interesting as
something to fit into this so we can
talk about that on another podcast but
very important to her to schedule things
out and if you see if we schedule it out
for say four or five weeks there are
times when we'll look at it we'll know
it's coming it's like okay are we gonna
do this and it's like now we're good
like there are times when we just we
don't have a critical mass of stuff to
talk about it's like now they can wait
like we'll just do it we can push it a
week yep and so it's it's but you you
want to from my experience thus far
better to have it on the calendar yeah
and then say hey we can play hook and
make it an opt out instead of Alton
exactly then to not have it on the
calendar and have to like hit DEFCON
five when things boil over dude
everything that's important in life
should be opt-out everything it should
be by default it's gonna happen it's on
the calendar and whether that is call
your mom every Sunday evening whether
that is go train at the gym three four
or five times a week whatever it is put
just that intentionality of writing it
down and putting it on the calendar
even the intentionality of everyone
listening and saying what are the four
things that I want to accomplish every
week I want to call my mom or dad I want
to train I want to whatever I want to
read a book for 10 minutes and then
putting those down on your calendar it
doesn't matter if it's in the morning or
night whatever works for you
that instantly separates you from being
opted in from
being buffeted by the winds left and
right and just going wherever the world
takes you you decide don't let the world
decide for you here here
super feet set the safety how do you say
your name Franklin
Ramiz say T ok so you have the second
edition of I will teach you to be rich
available and I'm sure but by the time
people hear this it may be available it
should be available and it has AE new
pages of material yeah tools insights
about money in psychology stories of
readers have used the book these scripts
that we were talking about yep and oh
yeah look at those real reader results
yeah yeah we're looking at how do they
look right now I wanted to show people
that rich a lot of people think rich
looks a certain way but I wanted to put
photos of these readers men women black
white young old everyone of us has
someone we want to see ourselves
represented you know I saw an ad on the
train for an Indian dad in Hindi and I
was like you know what ten years ago
that wouldn't have been meaningful to me
but now I'm actually appreciating and
represented so that's what I wanted in
this book and you you've tagged a couple
of things for me to check out later
which I will check out you got I'm just
gonna read the tabs you don't have to go
through all of stories next victim
culture which I'm sure you're a huge fan
of kidding word-for-word scripts ignore
reddit invisible scripts crypto love and
money so you got a lot here and as I
mentioned earlier oh I'm just gonna read
the first paragraph on the back of the
book because I haven't seen this in ages
just quick quick back story note I
remember when you were writing this oh I
came to you for advice and I gave you
your the I gave you a bird by bird by
Anne Lamott and but here's here's the
first paragraph of the back copy by as
many lattes as you want that's a
reference to people who recommend you
cut back on all these things like a lot
to spend extravagantly on the things you
love live your rich life instead of
tracking every last expense and you know
what I've what I've always enjoyed
observing
and learning from our the tests that you
do you experiment you actually implement
these things and you provide scripts and
actual algorithms for achieving very
specific results so awesome to see you
thank you dude it's been a pleasure I
love catching up and thanks for having
me on
yeah people can find you on twitter at
roommate instagram at roommate and
website i WT comm are there any other
places where people can check you out
see what you're up to or anything else
that you would like to say before we
wrap up this episode get the book it's
on Amazon and come visit me in any of
these social places and the site and the
newsletter and would love to talk more
with everyone about their rich life
ravit thanks so much for coming on
thanks a lot and to everyone who is
listening thank you for joining in you
can find the show notes links to
everything we've discussed at tim dot
blog forward slash podcast along with
every other episode and until next time
track wisely calendar the important [ __ ]
[Music]
plan you're batching sessions and thanks
for tuning in and i will be in touch
very soon
you